[Music]
how are things between you and John
hi work was good but I've been feeling a
little tired lately have you
you each have busy lives it's natural
don't worry kind of think of it I have
been a little tired you know what it is
yeah right you went to the Rialto bar
hey John getting something we had two
beers until your girlfriend finished
your [ __ ] over your girlfriend Elena
convinced you John
never seen you in the daylight before
I'll see you tonight
why didn't you tell me about her I
didn't tell you how did your girlfriend
is against the rule you have to break up
with I'm not gonna do that
and you have to tell her about us if you
want then I will single body multi
consciousness
you're really not that worried I still
don't get this what are you
I've been seeing his old girlfriend you
have to tell what have you been doing
what's going on
I don't like it when the two of you
aren't getting along you know how
serious this is you have to do something
about her
I thought you were thriving
something I need to tell you I love her
you
you